there are moments at this white house
podium which resonate they are
remembered and this may well be one of
them
to make the loss
of these
lives matter
not a president but an actor angry
hurting and with a pair of shoes that
belonged to one of the 19 children
killed in his hometown
they were
green high top converse
wore these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
with his wife he has spent much of the
past week with the families of those who
died in a week where lawmakers on
capitol hill are trying to see if they
can agree on new gun laws he urged for
unity and sense
we need responsible gun ownership
responsible gun ownership we need
background checks
responsible gun owners
are fed up
with the second amendment being abused
and hijacked by some deranged
individuals
these regulations are not a step back
step forward for civil society and
and the second amendment he's a gun
owner himself he acknowledged as much
but insisted that there is a way forward
there is not a democratic or republican
value in one single act of these
shooters it's not
but people in power
have failed to act so we're asking you
and i'm asking you will you please ask
yourselves
can both sides rise above
can both sides see beyond the political
problem at hand and admit that we have a
life preservation problem on our hands
and he's not wrong in the two weeks
since uvalde more than 700 people have
been shot dead in america 66 of them
teenagers 23 of them children it is the
politicians in here who are responsible
for pushing through change or not it is
on their shoulders and later today they
will hear from the parents
and the survivors of that day in new
valde
they will include mia cerrillo 11 years
old she covered herself in blood and
played dead in order to live
mark stone sky news in washington